[Music]
my name is Paul Dean but everybody calls
me Dixie
[Music]
all my life I've dreamt of walking in
the footsteps of the great Svengali z'
of rock and roll I do a very specific
kind of music here I know you only need
a mod like me waving your remote please
tell me you are wearing that ironically
give me six months I'll get you a record
deal
I got BS sadness
we'll make this kick like when the
pistols within the club but when the
balls pretty ICN them you'll get me my
money by the end of next week or you can
[ __ ] off back to the whales okay did you
come back to where those give us a shout
yeah I would rather eat my own art in
this balloon when do we pay by tomorrow
except check do our [ __ ] but you're
living in a dream world and I'm going to
my moms
[Music]
what they called the premature
congratulations ever heard of a so we
have the Scotsman over here in he's key
the prams are going to be massive your
trended on throughout we have the Scots
lady over here in she's key do I need it
so I don't think it takes a gradient to
work out about the next step with no
absolutely yeah and if you [ __ ]
interrupt me again
I will set you on fire
[Music]
I have a similar scheme when it's put in
London
[Music]
anything you need to call me anytime
about advice because I love the
spider-man I lover hello it's miss Dixie
I'm just making sure this is the number
and this is you this is you with it
[Music]